Tonight at six talk show hosts.
Glenn Beck has just been Donald duct.
How a bay area man used a cartoon
to mock the media star. That's next.
Well,
it's not a campaign ad,
but you can't tell us a lot about the
changing world of politics alongside the
dancing babies and yawning.
Panders one very pointed political
satire is getting huge hits on Youtube.
Mike Sugarman shows us how one guy in a
San Francisco apartment can change the
discussion all across the country
in a nondescript mission district
apartment building in a tiny room lives at
David who has taken on a Goliath.
Awesome.
This is the center of the, uh,
vast conspiracy against Glenn Beck.
Jonathan McIntosh didn't use a
sling shot instead of computer,
he took aim at one of America's most
controversial talk show hosts who he
despises and goosed him with a duck.
How many Marxist Communist
anticapitalist you have around you?
He worked three months,
sometimes 10 hours a day on a video mashup
of Glenn Beck mixed with Donald Duck.
It's gone viral.
At least half a million hits since it's
released Saturday among them, Glenn Beck,
Donald Duck meets Glenn back.
It is some of the best wellmade
propaganda I have ever seen.
This is where it gets
crazy if I'm not mistaken.
Some of these remix videos I
believe get federal funding.
We're looking into the funding of
this gentleman fairly funded. No,
I have no funding at all.
This is just me and my computer in my,
in my living room. Uh, in fact,
I, you know, I, I just, uh,
I just lost my job and last last month,
which gave me some free time and
that's the reason that I was able to,
to put this together in the video.
Donald Duck loses his job and starts
listening to the BEC radio show.
The depression era cartoon and Beck's
musings seem to pair well out of context.
Of course, there are Nazis in
America, Nazis and communists.
You have to think like a German.
June,
1934 at Walt Disney was very conservative,
isn't lost on Macintosh either.
He revels in the satire.
Liberals are loving and Beck
is hating. I like that. I'm,
I'm able to speak back to him and that,
um,
people using remix or I'm using
youtube, you know, are, are,
are able to speak back and that,
that there can be a larger voice for
those of us who don't have a radio station
and a TV station,
because now the people who do
less worry about getting shot.
So again, this came out
Saturday and how did it spread?
Will Roger Ebert Sot he tweeted
it. John Cusack, the actor side,
he tweeted it and it would,
it really goes to show is just
how in this media environment,
one person can throw open the can of
worms to the entire political world.
Has Disney weighed in on this? Well,
it's fair use from what I understand.
Mr Mackintosh says,
um,
but I don't know mean that's what he
says. It's a lot of Disney material. Yeah.
He's going to get a job and
a good one. Well, you know,
he worked very hard on
this. Yeah. Good for him.